ce serait mes couilles non mais c'est
vrai
non mais y'a pas un mot normal qui sort
de sa douche c'est un super place
al-tahrir
voire plus si un bon mois 20 ans de
moins et 20 centimètres de moi dans 82 m
et faire un médecin dit ce
magnifique comme ça il a suffi à créer
votre beauté janin je vois arriver aux
illuminés la france franchement 10 cm de
moins ça j'aurais j'aurais signé quoi en
fait 72 est très belle comme ça 86 ans
tient un peu passif moi je moi aussi je
voulais 10 cm de haut
[Rires]
mais çà et là et elle m'a marqué mais
c'est le grand retour de nicolas
pernikoff trois émissions de suie et oui
alors là franchement on est c'est vrai
le malheur des uns
mais je vous le dis à mon avis
je vous le dis dès qu'un hacker maladie
est content c'est vrai vous avez vu
comment vous rentrez tout de suite est
revenu très vite j'ai tout de suite dès
que vous avez eu parce que benjamin a
failli mourir non et c'est tout rien
perdu
non je vais un virus foudroyant 39,6
pendant 24 heures c'est quoi le virus
bah je ne sais pas vous mais ça fait
deux fois que vous avez un virus chez
nous à deux fois bah si tu avais
une bactérie dans l'estomac la cena
virus ne sais pas et moi du choc tout ça
je ne sais pas
et attendent un moine entraîner chez
nulle part vous trompez votre femme
j'étais sûr de les y
voit là bas vous joue sans salle annie
des instruments propres castaldi c'est
le naproxcinod d'heure après trois pages
peux te dire que tu m'as dans le cif à
mon avis tanner surprise un avis c'est
moi qui
alors là moi je n'aurais pas dû dire
l'occasion d'y aller au vote contient
trois endroits non mais si oui non si
bien fumé qui ont été reculés
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez
un virus mais moi je ne savais pas ce
que c'est j'ai beaucoup de bourgeonner
comme ça la fleur au fusil mais j'ai
fait contaminer tout le monde et non
j'ai fait le test que vite j'ai fait
appel à un médecin mais il va ce n'est
pas contagieux c'est un vilain virus
mais c'est un disque qui t'ont médecin
l'a écouté ça je te dis que tu me semble
très malade j'ai pas mal du tout
principe d'un virus est contagieux
répète ça toi c'est pas une bactérie e
d'études bon ça
va adapter la fin de l'âge de
l'information
c'est pareil merci vont pas se mouiller
changeriez monde et non sergiolin
complexion non non il ya bien le
retrouver je suis pas d'accord
sinon ça va vous changeriez coin alors
20 ans de moins et 20 centimètres de
plus aux jambes ce qui m'évite convoi
vendetta
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on ait vu
anormalement fait déjà rire j'étais né
année
incroyable excusez moi voilà oui vous
bien droit qu'à une seule chose non
invasif et hong kong
oreilles mais ouais dans les épaules
après j'essaie pour le pointu continue
les ans il a des gens magnifiques hadji
ouais ça c'est là des gens mariés vous
pouvez montrer aux gens à dire au revoir
au talon non mais sérieux quand quelques
actions
areva dans ce cube à la formidable c'est
un bon soldat j'ai dit non non si tu
veux pas tu le fais pas tu relève juste
le bac tampon non mais
vous me dit de montrer mes jambes
mais là il va pas montré par en bas des
pantalons qu'est-ce qui fait ce débit
[Applaudissements]
dans 400 badaoui s'emmerde pas attendu
non merde pas il ya des enfants qui
rentrent de l'école tu sais pas pourquoi
mais on s'est dit on lui dit dessapt os
des séries comme ça sert l'amour et
c'est un très grand joueur brind'amour
les applaudissements voilà voilà
delphine wespiser alors et rien n'était
prêt 107 les fesses tout seul c'est vrai
je me rajouterai commande la poitrine à
ses intuitions
mais c'est vrai c'est la vérité c'est
vrai ouais mal final je me rajoute
réduit oui oui là il faut mettre à
écrire des conneries au duel et bâti
elle finit pas fait on sait très bien
qu'à la haye la l1 il faudrait que
rajouter
à l'aller face plate on dirait une table
de ping pong
jusqu'aujourd'hui la mode c'est hyper
bombay j'arrête pas faire moi des fois
il ya des morts elle arrive et leurs
fesses avec ce
que géraldine savary sauf que jean
lamoot ça change à bombay
que roger l'a pas le temps d'attendre la
mode la
séance aux attentes et cela motive
explique on est mal qu'est-ce qui ont
duré huit mois femmes en cdinotre
le visage et tout est parfaitement
infondée 10 cm de plus maintenant de
très beaux conakry à quel endroit c'est
bien tu est rapide j'aime bien je m'en
sens capable mais très bon achat 115
oued rhiou et et rappelez moi je tombe
je trouve très bien comme ça dans ta
d'été très belle marie anne est un des
très beaux seins
non mais vraiment très très belle jambe
mais vraiment je trouve tes jambes
horrible molly sweeney ces monnaies
envisagez vous êtes armé
serait déjà dit jalabert l'action
cassano n'est pas de molette et voir ma
porte est bercy largement non
protégeant métal à
tomber je n'enlève en rien non mais dis
moi c'est quoi ce show syrte après les
chaussures de ton petit
cadeau l'artus du 36 et là c'est pas
vraiment horrible avec quoi c'est
bon c'est bon
et pousse un peu j'ai tapé
ses 13 ans prennent effet attention
c'est simplement d'emballage et rien
faire
je suis pas le déboisement est bon alors
je te défonce à évasion le film pourtant
il faut plutôt si moi je voudrais
[Applaudissements]
et
attention tu dévoue
légende dit glace quad et
ça va
vous êtes plusieurs là dedans
alors va tenter d'adapter matt damon et
d'une coque est dégoûtant nepad a fui
histoire ya des gens chez carla c'est ce
à quoi devrait passer en vulgaire déjà
là mais si les gens sont des jambes de
bouffe la rsa les connais pas mais je
suis un beau voir et thanh hoa globaux
tu vas voir je suis un bon contact
non mais c'est
bien en jambes tu as d'une jambe en
métal
si longtemps on garde
tout à monter à bicyclette ils s'en
foutent et non mais géraldine vous qui
connaissez bien les jambes qu'est ce que
vous pouvez dire dit la vérité alors
c'est ses deux salles deux angoisses
celle de benjamin ça un petit peu plus
rustique un bref et compagnie
c'est vrai que dans la boue avec des
bottes en caoutchouc mois et votre sens
un tout petit peu plus raffiné ses
limites au niveau des gâteaux exactement
ce qu'il fallait de très bas mais c'est
vrai ça
non pas du tout pas du tout il est raide
et raymond kopa l'on voit là où il n'a
pas de journal non
[Applaudissements]
jamais joda parce que là ce qu'il aime
jouer les deux immeubles art il est prêt
pas du tout j'ai essayé par simone free
pas derrière les décors tapas de cuisse
et a placé mais ses frères de division
quoi lui
vision hongrois attendent des bisous
jamais vous plaît allez pour faire les
jambes et pas pour faire même si
ailleurs et me prend vous montrez pas
vos jambes étaient 120 je fais un
complexe non c'est parce que c'est mieux
en fait il faudrait que je les travaille
deux fois plus que le haut à deux fois
jambes dans la semaine je n'avais qu'une
fois mais ça vous que jambes c'est
affligeant que c'est dur et notamment de
jean mineur après tu envie de vomir et
tous ces 50% de ton corps donc été
crevés tout ça donc voilà ouais mais
c'est pas ça que je changerais malgré
tout c'est quoi
alors parce que chez nous c'est un pas
d'abord b n'est pas abolie en rêverait
de faire un mètre soixante dix huit donc
je voudrais rajouter huit centimètres
mam était descendu
sans rigoler ce qu'elle nous dit on mais
c'est tout
sinon elle est au top voilà non moi
j'aurais aimé j'avoue ce que chez nous
c'est important mais un cinéma
distinction j'aurais bien aimé atteindre
le vin quoi avoir une main
une tête devant quoi
attention c'est moi j'adore attention la
mine la mire est très bien mais j'aurais
aimé avoir le contenu d habiles à 100 il
est très bien
bah oui tu vois que tu te bats les
cliques et une lambo quoi quand même si
tu médites et des lambeaux dans ton slip
métier de lambeaux dont on taira mais
nommé ben c'est hyper rare c'est 1 1%
avec 1 % quoi alors à toi toi quand tu
as tu fait rare non mais quand tu tombes
est un mec en ce moment oui fait ah
oui non
[Rires]
cette fois
je pense que sa mère ne regarde tous les
soirs et m'envoie à chaque fois un texto
de débrief de l'émission
n'ont été très bien bravo madame c'est
très bien voilà mes mais c'est pas ben
ben c'est très rares personnes à redon
ici ouais quel intérêt d'avoir
très important mais c'est pas à temps si
tu as un contrôle de géométrie
manquerait plus que basser handicap ou
s'il te plaît tu nous a soufflé
est ici on parle sérieux tu vois ouais
bah de football pas du tout je montrais
mes jambes bah oui à la bouée même jour
année la digue était très chic oui oui
vous changera quelque chose vous vous
estimez vous êtes parfait non
franchement non je j'aimerais bien avoir
des
je peux pas vous le dire non mais moi
j'aurai sûrement jouer et j'aurais aimé
avoir des abdos mais très peu de
tunisiens d abdou sané
tu manges 3 chakchouka par jour non mais
sa gueule et tu peux faire deux sur
mille abdos par jour c'est pas possible
sans déconner nous on n'a que urrma r on
a en fait on éventre dur parce que c'est
vrai on a des abdos vous n'êtes pas mais
ils sont chez cas
c'est à dire les ados ils sortent jamais
à andy bon c'est bon t'as tué 120 kg non
ce que tu vois tu peux te guérir matière
c'est dur tu vois c'est dur pour moi
allez olla oui
je sais que c'est dur en six classes et
devrait malheureusement ces dessous
c'est ne souffre pas sculpté c'est
horrible c'est horrible non mais moi
c'est pas des tablettes de chocolat chez
les dames le cas ici
ça c'est un vrai problème c'est vrai moi
j'ai un corps de
deux tunisiens
[Rires]
ouais
voilà
c'est con mais c'est vrai j'ai pas été
gâté non mais vraiment un retard est
fermé mais toi ça te va bien comme ça
tant avec des habous serait pas beau ce
genre c'est pas ton style non mais t'as
pas t'es pas du genre à voir ça est très
bien comme ça vous ça va sinon moi je
suis dégueulasse méchant pleine
transformation sinon si vous
jetez vous regardez dans le vide depuis
tout à l'heure déprimant va
beaucoup mieux non je suis déménagé
pernikoff eu longuement au téléphone ce
matin et alors bon on a débriefé de face
à baba il a une idée d'émission c'est
qu'on avait dit j'aimerais nivet face à
père ni mais face à quelqu'un pendant
trois heures et je lui raconte des
anecdotes sur la téloche comme on savait
l'affairé en 2004 sort
[Applaudissements]